Speaker 1: Donald Trump imploded like a tantrum
ing child pooping in the sandbox so nobody
else can play in it. Over the criminal referrals
approved by the House of Representatives committee
investigating the Trump riots of January six,
2021. Let's go right to the horse's mouth, for
lack of a better term. Donald Trump, starting with
a statement. Let's get this right on the screen
properly for you, a statement on the January 6th
committee referral. These folks don't get it that
when they come after me, people who love freedom
rally around me. It strengthens me. What doesn't
kill me makes me stronger. Americans know that I
pushed for 20,000 troops to prevent violence on
January 6th. That is a lie. First, Trump claimed
he wanted 10,000 troops. Now he says it's 20.
There's no evidence that he ever made that request
and that I went on television and told everyone to
go home. He did that hours into the riots and
still said the rioters are justified for being
there and being angry because the election was
stolen, which wasn't Trump continuing. Think of
it. The radical left Democrats Communists spied on
my campaign. That's a lie. Lied to the FISA court.
That's a lie. Lied to Congress. Many people have
lied to Congress. It doesn't actually change the
reality of this. And of course, when Trump's
people lied to Congress, they all said lying
to Congress is no big deal allowed an invasion of
our country on the southern border policy has not
substantively changed since Trump under Biden on
the border embarrassed us in Afghanistan. Biden
did the same thing Trump said he was going
to do gave away our energy independence. We
actually are more overproducing under Biden
in terms of oil than we were under Trump.
Killed us on job losing regulations. Meaningless
and vague. Wouldn't use the 10,000 plus soldiers
I recommended for January 6th. In his last troth,
he said it was 20,000. Wrote The number changes
refuse to look into election fraud. The reason
for January 6th rigged and stole the 2020 election
allowed ballot stuffing, FBI, Facebook, Twitter
and Biden crime. That's just a mess. That's just
a word salad. And he continues continued from
previous truth. And I'm the one that the corrupt
and partizan on select committee goes after a two
tiered, quote, justice system. And by the way,
whatever happened with the massive number
of crimes committed by Joe and Hunter Biden,
we're unaware of any such crimes as of right
now. They're right. They're documented and
100% certain. Also, where's the prosecutor from?
Delaware. What happened to him as he friends with
the Ukrainian prosecutor who didn't prosecute
after Biden held up the billion dollar payment
to Ukraine? I did nothing wrong in all caps. As
you see, he's losing it. Then he starts retweeting
various videos, propaganda videos, including one
that refers to Adam Schiff, though Schiff retweets
a message from Elise Stefanik. Post-Super Bowl.
A video of Alan Dershowitz. Another video of Alan
Dershowitz promotes truth essential and then is
just posting stuff on and on and on and then picks
it back up again. This morning, with almost no
delay, files conclusively revealed that the FBI
totally discredited, damning and by the way, he
spells damning the way a beaver does. You know,
beavers are damning stuff. It's just beyond
parody. Damning factual information from Hunter
Biden's laptop from hell. It's just on and
on here. It's only even tangential. And then
he goes full conspiracy. The so-called deep
state, often referred to by many other names,
including cheaters, insurrectionists, communists
and yes, even our good old rhinos have been
working on sinister and evil plots for a long
time, even well before I came to office. They are
long seeded swamp creatures and are bad news for
the USA. Blah blah blah blah blah. He then goes
after the committee that sent the referrals. I see
where the UN Select Committee using the Democrat's
favorite weapon disinformation is trying to make
the case that I didn't really believe I won the
election. That's a total lie. I never thought for
even a moment that the presidential election of
2020 was not rigged and stolen, and my conviction
became even stronger as time went by. Now,
with all of the massive evidence that has
come to light, including recently with the
FBI suppression of election changing information,
I was 100% right. Hours, hours, untruth, social.
Speaker 2: Censure.
Speaker 1: Spreading lies and being
triggered. Now, at the end of the day, the next
step is up to the Department of Justice. Is the
Department of Justice. Is Merrick Garland ready
and willing to do what we all know is supported
by the facts? And that is what that is to charge
Donald Trump. Do I believe he will spend the day
in prison? I still do not. But do I believe it
would be the correct thing to charge him? I would,
because that's a decision you make based on
the evidence. Let me know if you expect charges
against Donald Trump. Friday, December 23rd.
We are doing our final membership special of
the year. Everyone's first month's payment will
be donated by us to an organization that sends
cash to people who really need it. And it will
be doubled. So hypothetical. Okay. Memberships
are six bucks a month. Friday we get you a coupon.
Code saves you 50%. You pay three bucks, we donate
the three bucks. You still keep the membership
and we double the $3 with six. We match the first
$15,000. We've never done this before. I want you
to participate. I want you to be involved. All you
have to do is get on my mailing list by signing
up at David Pakman dot com. The box to enter your
email is at the top right of the website. More on
Friday. Very exciting. Quick break. Be right back.